check out our sponsors
nature's blends they specialize in
premium ethiopian black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their products
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are wearing inshallah my
name is i am eddie
she was great introduction she's smiling
to your face you energy english
yeah my english not very well very good
no not very good yes a little bit
english
that's good so what we're going to do
today we're going to be talking about
something very important
this thing here so this you would see
maybe a lot of cultures yes a lot of
countries
so i heard like you know be it iran uh
greece uh turkey's known for it
everywhere you go you see it
um so we're gonna talk a bit about this
i'm gonna learn some lessons from this
because the reason i'm doing this video
is because of my
kurdish turkish culture uh we have this
as well you see everywhere you see it
especially on babies
newborn babies small ones that they put
on and we're going to find out
why so i'm just going to get from my
mom's perspective originally
um
now that could be because it's derived
because i've told her about this over
the years
that this is
foreign
[Music]
um
so she said yes exactly that's why the
eyes they say because even iran is there
to protect
you from that so now obviously my mom's
understanding obviously i've been
telling
her she doesn't know but obviously
sometimes you know those old habits
leave you a heart um
it cannot protect me from itself because
i can smash it forward i can just
register the pieces yeah
which i'm going to do after with great
delight you know i'm going to do it and
start smashing it
but the point is this now a lot of
turkish families turkish kurdish
or if you have this in your house you
might be from a different background the
point is this broken system you might
see this as something very
um trivial something not really
important we just put it but what
happens is these two decisions
grow you know and one of the reasons i
found that because this goes back three
thousand years ago it's not even
probably
any religion yet so basically what i
found out is that
yes okay although the nazis attributed
to turkey the symbol goes back about
three thousand years ago
it is said that the nazar mondrian can
be traced to ancient egypt where the eye
of the god of
osiris was believed to have protected
powers and from
from this group the idea of the
benevolent eye
so the thing is what we're trying to
raise here is brothers and sisters is to
educate your family members don't go
home and start going and imagine and
start
uh go home and just start getting these
things and start smashing down
you know getting excited like yeah
there's nothing my wisdom behind that
yeah you're gonna make your family think
you know you've lost the plot
so the thing is it's very important to
educate because i've been telling my mom
about this and she says that herself
but the point is though sometimes those
habits stay with you so they'll be like
oh it's just we're just leaving it there
and what happens is if you believe
that um i was watching this in the video
if you believe that this protects you
with the will of
allah that's a form of minor [ __ ] if you
believe
this this thing protects you that's his
major [ __ ] and we know the dangers of
[ __ ] brothers and sisters
and it's easy like we have quran
[Music]
has given us something to protect
ourselves and what's the translation of
that to be exact
say i see refuge in the lord of the day
from the evil of that which he created
and from the evil of the darkness when
he set when it settles and from the evil
of the blows and the not
those who do magical and from the evil
of an envia when he envies
so brahmana says when you look at the
tafseer of this you can see that it
talks about evil eye
one thing that i found out also was that
just a little fact is that when they put
this
was that the point was that the
attention and the hindus
if i'm not mistaken hindus do this as
well you know that they'll put a black
dot on a
baby's head so that the person can't
focus will go and they are not on the
baby and give the people baby evil eye
so what they would do is they would use
it as a destruction tool
so what happened is eventually though as
human beings and that's the reason why
there's dangers
and these kind of acts because it turns
out to be [ __ ] and people
have this in their car if you go to
shops and stuff like that they think
this in itself plays a role in the
protection and we believe this is a form
of minor ship or even
actual ship so we want to cleanse our
family members
from this you know uh battle is it's
falsehood you know
and when truth comes it smashes and i'm
gonna smash it but not now maybe
i might do a little thing
my
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
these are superstitious things yeah like
open the umbrella going under a certain
billboard or whatever it may be
these are all superstitious things
that's why we have the quota to abide by
brother sisters
my mom is obviously like you know she's
learning and like i said she has those
uh old habits there and they don't do
that easily so i have
i'm educating her with these specific
things as well and like i said before
brother and sisters
um it's very important for us to
understand the dangers of this
and to protect ourselves from that that
protection is from allah and the reason
why we fall into these things and why
the reward for paradise is there for
those who believe in allah without
seeing him
extinct
[Music]
one of the reasons why we have this as
human beings is we have this kind of
craving to it
is because we like to see things real
things that we see
that we will say okay this protects well
we have the quran we have
at morning and evening we have the quran
as a
as a cure it's secure superannuation but
what happens is because it's something
tangible in the context of we don't see
okay i recite something okay i can't see
why i recited
it's not there well that's why some
people get amulets and stuff like that
quran
why because as human beings we have this
craving allah maybe created us in that
way to have that but
the ones who follow the quran that in
the correct way
will follow what is what that is
messenger and will not
try to find solutions in handmade things
that's a reason why a lot of people went
into idol worship
because because they can't see allah
they want to go on to something that
they can tangibly feel and touch
even though it cannot neither bring them
home or bring them any kind of benefit
because the statue in itself can be
harmed and you can if you can if i
go and smash this it's not going to be
able to help itself
from me let alone protect you so
promises this was a video from me and my
mom inshallah i'm going to be touching
upon a few other cultural aspects
the turkish people have which we're
going to do doing inshallah
to break down certain things and is to
educate you inshallah so please share
this message with wisdom
please do not go to your house i don't
want parents coming and telling me yeah
my son watched a video came home i
started smashing all the eyes in the
house and started setting the place on
fire yeah please have some wisdom okay
and first you should obey your parents
unless they call you to [ __ ] if they
tell you to carry that that's a
different story yeah
um you know like sometimes before my mom
used to tell me to laugh
gently you would say no yeah and do not
forget to honor your parents respect
your parents allah says after i command
you to worship me is to be good to the
parents and do not even say words of uff
to them inshallah and if you want any
kind of barakah in your life benefit
don't find barakah in these things find
barakah and be obedient to your parents
good to people inshallah and get closer
to allah
foreign
she just puts it as like you know as an
aesthetic just to make it look nice
as you can see it goes much like a
little rhythm